wir kommen zu unserer nächsten
zuschauerfrage die kommt von markus
lipinsky
er will wissen werden schufa einträge
automatisch tag genau gelöscht oder muss
man da hinterher laufen
nein die werden automatisch gelöscht und
auch tag genau das ist
selbstverständlich
dann kommen wir zur nächsten zu müssen
video nämlich von olaf mühlenberg aus
schwellen seine frage
zum thema schuldenfalle habe ich eine
etwas andere geschichte zu erzählen weil
ich stehe auf der anderen seite ich bin
nicht der schuldner ich bin der
gläubiger und zwar habe ich vor geraumer
zeit einen jungen mann aus meinem
bekanntenkreis einen geldbetrag in höhe
von 10.000 euro berlin wie nicht zu
erwarten war was mich total also
wirklich total irritiert hat ist die
tatsache dass dieser mensch niemals auch
nur einen rat an mich zurückgezahlt hat
dann bekam ich dann jetzt irgendwie im
april oder so dieses jahres die
mitteilung dass das verfahren aufgrund
bezahlt nicht fest dass das verfahren
wegen geringfügigkeit eingestellt worden
sei das ist eine unverschämtheit und
selbst das ist möglich hier in
deutschland
ja tatsächlich da die frage an ingo koch
kann ich auch als privater gläubiger der
schufa negatives über meinen kunden
melden
nein das geht nicht man muss um an die
schufa informationen melden zu können
genauso auch um informationen beziehen
zu können
vertragspartner sein und wenn man das
nicht ist dann kann man auch keine
information ein melden aber in einem
solchen fall ist es natürlich
grundsätzlich so dass wenn jemand einem
anderen auf privater basis geld geliehen
hatten das ganze ist vertraglich
dokumentiert dann hat er ja einen
anspruch darauf dass der vertrag erfüllt
wird das gleiche gilt ja auch für
private verträge und möglicherweise gibt
es dann zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
einen entsprechenden titel den er wirkt
gegen den schuldner der nicht bezahlt
und ein solcher titel der wird ja
festgestellt wird dann noch zugestellt
vom gerichtsvollzieher und in den
entsprechenden registergericht uns
dieser amtsgerichten eingetragen und
solche informationen werden dann
wiederum an die schufa übermittelt bzw
von der schufa und andere auskunfteien
in die datenbestände übernommen so dass
damit dann trotzdem ein schutz anderer
die möglicherweise auch privat geld
leihen
theoretisch möglich ist